I'm not only here to learn how to be a
wire walker from you I'm learning how to
tell your story Philippe not only taught
him how to walk on the wire but taught
him with magic tricks and juggling and
of course when I talked to Joe about
this he said the thing that I enjoyed
about this more than anything was just
to be with Philippe for all those days
and just get a feel of who this guy was
and of course that was all of his prep
for the character it was a serious
challenge but I like a challenge since
we started working with a line on the
floor yeah then with a bar on the floor
then with about 17 inches of the floor
then with a little cable live cable that
vibrates two feet off and then the cable
you know six feet high seven eight
very well tied did you feel this move
from an inanimate object the ground bar
they're dead metal to the life of the
cable yeah it's very different after
this even brief amount of time what I've
learned is the balance comes much easier
being in motion